Guten Morgen, Thomas!
Guten Morgen, Tim!
Du, ich hab hier grad einen Pinguin gesehen. Er ist in die Ferne entflohen.
But why?
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 544 vom 30., wie man so schön sagt, Jänner, 2026.
Danke sehr. Ja, bitteschön. Du hast es ja so in die Notizen geschrieben, Thomas.
Ja, sicher. Januar, da muss mein Kopf immer umrechnen. Jänner ist der Jänner.
Ja, und dann kommt Februar, oder was?
Februar.
Februar. Ja, natürlich. Ich habe da kein richtiges Wort für.
Ja. Das ist nicht das richtige Wort.
Minimalistisch, na gut. Jänner, der Schnee fällt.
Der Jänner ist der Montag des Jahres.
Der Jänner ist der Montag des Jahres. Da ist was dran.
Du meinst also Wochenende vorbei.
Ganz genau.
Nobody likes Mondays, nobody likes January.
Da muss man halt durch außer den Skifahrern, die finden das glaube ich ganz toll du weißt.
Ich bin ein schlechter Österreicher in der Hinsicht Skifahren,
Klettern, damit kannst du mich jaucken.
Ja, ist das so.
Bin ich nicht dabei. Das machen alle und deswegen muss es uncool sein.
Da musst du einfach anders drauf sein. Verstehe. Ja, okay. Ja,
geht mir auch so. Ich kann mit Wintersport auch herzlich wenig anfangen.
Deswegen bin ich dahin geflohen, wo die Pinguine entfliehen.
Ich beneide dich sehr. Es gibt wirklich süße Pinguine auch in Südafrika, dort wo du bist.
Ja, aber ich muss zugeben, ich habe tatsächlich keinen in die Ferne entfliehen
sehen. Bis du mir vorhin vor der Sendung über dieses wunderbare Meme aufgeklärt
hast, was ich ehrlich gesagt noch gar nicht auf dem Zeiger hatte.
Ich bin sowieso ein großer Werner Herzog Fan und das, was er da mit dieser Dokumentation
von der Antarktis schon vor einigen Jahren da gemacht hat, fand ich wirklich cool.
Und das ist jetzt seit ein paar Wochen.
Auf einmal geht das durch die Decke und es gibt tausende Remixes davon und Swag
und überall sind nur noch Pinguine und dieses But Why.
Ich glaube, das trifft sehr gut unseren kulturellen Moment, dass sich alle Leute
fragen, ist das jetzt immer so?
Muss das so sein? Wann hört das auf? Und wieso machen wir gerade noch, was wir tun?
Ich glaube, die Sinnfrage ist gerade sehr groß.
Ja, na gut, ich meine, das war ja während Corona auch so ein bisschen vielleicht
mit einem anderen Unterton gespielt.
Und vielleicht ist es dann aber auch so in der Summe, also diese Dichte der
Ereignisse, die den Leuten dann doch zu schaffen macht.
Und ich kann das auch ganz gut nachvollziehen, jeder hat ja auch so seine eigene
Art und Weise mit solchen Momenten umzugehen.
Also man muss jetzt nicht wie dieser nihilistische Pinguin einfach in die Ferne
50 Kilometer Richtung Südpol latschen.
Das ist vielleicht eine Methode, aber es macht ja auch nur ein Pinguin.
Alle anderen bleiben zusammen, wärmen sich gegenseitig, haben Spaß,
rutschen auf den Bauch über den Schnee, gehen schwimmen, also essen viel Fisch.
Also das sind eigentlich Dinge, die könnten wir auch unseren Hörerinnen und
Hörern durchaus empfehlen, um gut bei Laune zu bleiben.
Das sagt sich leicht, wenn du gerade per 30 Grad in der Nähe des Meeres bist.
Die Idee finde ich schön.
Naja, aber ich meine, sei wie ein Pinguin, nur gerade halt nicht wie der nihilistische Pinguin.
Hast du eine These, warum? Warum geht der Pinguin in die Ferne? Ist das Verzweiflung?
Naja, ich meine einer von hunderttausend oder es gibt halt immer wieder mal
solche, die sich gegen die Gruppe entscheiden, die vielleicht auch,
egal ob das jetzt Wahnsinn ist oder Genie oder Abenteuertum oder einfach nur
der innere Kompass dieses einen Tieres ist halt off und er verirrt sich.
Aber ich glaube, wir Menschen lesen da ganz viel rein in so ein Tier,
weil wir gerade selber uns fragen, was vielleicht noch die richtige Richtung ist.
Und das spricht, glaube ich, auf ganz vielen Ebenen zu dem, was Menschen heute so gerade durchmachen.
Und dann diese Mischung noch mit dieser beruhigenden Stimme von Herzog und dem
Gigi D'Agostino-Lied, was auf der Kirchenorgel nachgespielt wurde.
Ich glaube, dieses Meme hat halt verschiedene Ebenen, die alle gut resonieren gerade.
Ja, so erkläre ich es mir.
Okay, naja. Also unsere Hörerinnen und Hörer haben auf jeden Fall alles richtig
gemacht. Ihr habt bei Lockbox-Netzpolitik reingeschaltet.
Da ist die Apokalypse noch unterhaltsam.
Yeah. Genau.
Gucken wir noch mal, was wir so Apokalyptisches für euch zusammengetragen haben.
Womit fangen wir an? Ich würde sagen, du, ähm,
Spielst du mal deine Stolten aus und berichtest ein bisschen aus der EU.
Ganz genau. Wir haben gleich mal ein paar EU-Themen. Und in der letzten Sendung,
wo ich dabei sein durfte, das war die 535, haben wir schon über den Omnibus der EU gesprochen.
Und wieso das nichts mit irgendwelchen Bussen zu tun hat, sondern mit Gesetzeswerken,
die so ganz viele verschiedene Dinge zusammenpacken und dann en bloc abstimmen lassen.
Zu diesen Omnibussen gab es auch einen Vortrag am 39C3 von Ralf Bendrath und
mir, den wir hier auch nochmal verlinken und als Update dazu und zu dem,
was in der letzten Sendung gesagt wurde,
wir reden hier halt von der Deregulierungsagenda.
Im Moment, also dieser jetzige Gesetzgebungsperiode, Ursula von der Leyen kam
ja letztes Jahr wieder an die Macht und hat ihre zweite Amtszeit angetreten
und die steht unter dem Vorzeichen der Deregulierung, also der Vereinfachung,
des Abschaffen von Regeln.
Man will eigentlich nicht mehr so viele unnötige oder lästige Umweltschutzregeln
haben, Arbeitnehmerinnenschutz.
Alles, was Konzert in dem Wege steht, soll abgeschafft werden.
Das ist so die Denke dieser Kommission.
Die ist natürlich auch getragen davon, dass es jetzt zum ersten Mal eine rechtsrechte
Mehrheit im Europaparlament gibt.
Und in den digitalen Belangen gibt es da drei Gesetze, auf die man ein Auge haben sollte.
Das erste, es ist auch schon bald fertig verhandelt, da geht es um Small und
Medium Mid Caps, also um kleinere und mittlere Unternehmen und eigene Regeln
und Vereinfachungen, die man für diese machen will.
Da ist man fast fertig in den Verhandlungen und es geht nur noch um die Schwellenwerte.
Also ab wann bist du klein genug, dass du diese Ausnahmen in Anspruch nehmen darfst?
Beim AI-Act gibt es auch einen Omnibus, der die Regeln für künstliche Intelligenz abschwächen soll.
Das ist insbesondere gefährlich, weil da geht es um Gesichtserkennung,
da geht es um Predictive Policing, um KI, die der Chef am Arbeitsplatz einsetzt
gegen die eigenen MitarbeiterInnen.
Da geht es um Social Scoring, wie wir das aus dem Jobcenter kennen,
dass halt ein Computer entscheidet, ob du nochmal eine Schulung bezahlt bekommst
oder mehr Förderungen kriegst.
Ja, und all diese Regeln für KI, die sollten mit dem AI Act im August dann endgültig in Kraft treten.
Auch die Regeln für die Hochrisikosysteme.
Jene sind die, die noch nicht in Kraft sind.
Und ja, da wird aber jetzt mit diesem Omnibus dran geschraubt,
sodass diese noch nicht mal in Kraft getretenen Regeln wieder aufgeweicht werden.
Und da haben wir auch am Kongress im Vortrag noch viel mehr gesagt.
Eine positive Nachricht, die wir schon verlauten können aus den Verhandlungen
bisher ist, dass es scheinbar man sich nicht auf den faulen Deal einlässt,
dass man den Unternehmen erlaubt, sie selber frei zu deklarieren von Hochrisikoauflagen,
ohne das irgendjemandem sagen zu müssen.
Es gibt immer noch das Loophole, man kann sich dieser Regeln entziehen,
wenn man es an die Regulierungsbehörde meldet, aber das wollte die Kommission
abschaffen, sozusagen du machst einen internen Vermerk, gilt für mich nicht
und damit kannst du das Gesetz ignorieren.
Das wollen sogar die Mitgliedstaaten nicht und sagen, okay, aber du musst zumindest
der Regulierungsbehörde Bescheid geben und die muss das in ein öffentliches
Transparenzregister geben.
Das ist so der Stand in das Verhandlungsteam für den AI-Act-Omnibus,
haben wir auch schon, das schaut auch gar nicht so schlecht aus. Ja.
Da wird jetzt auch gerade auf Hochtouren verhandelt, weil das Ganze soll ja im August schon gelten.
Das heißt, da muss man für EU-Verhältnisse relativ flott zu Ergebnissen kommen.
Ja und dann gibt es noch den großen Omnibus, den Digital Omnibus.
Da geht es um die Datenschutzgrundverordnung und andere Datengesetze für nicht
personenbezogene Daten, wie zum Beispiel auch Open Data.
Aber bei der DSGVO, davon haben vielleicht auch die meisten schon gehört,
da geht es ans Eingemachte.
Und unter anderem um die Definition von dem, was überhaupt personenbezogene
Daten sind, eigene Regeln, dass du zum Beispiel Datenverarbeitung,
die für KI ist, anders behandelst als andere Datenverarbeitungen.
Das ist natürlich das Hauptsteckenpferd von
Ralf Bendrat, der damals die Datenschutzgrundverordnung mitverhandelt hat.
Dementsprechend persönlich nimmt er das auch. Und da haben wir noch kein Verhandlungsteam im Rat.
Und gleichzeitig gibt es kein Verhandlungsteam im Parlament,
so rum ist es richtig, aber im Rat gibt es gute Nachrichten.
Und das ist ja unüblich eigentlich, aber es dürften sich jetzt wirklich einige
Mitgliedstaaten ganz stark gegen diesen Kommissionsvorschlag positionieren.
Unter anderem Belgien, Estland, Kroatien, Österreich, Niederlande sind da wirklich
generell ablehnend auf viele dieser Punkte.
Gegenüber jetzt des gesamten Omnibus-Pakets oder jetzt konkret nur was die DSGVO,
also die Datenschutzgrundverordnung betrifft?
Letzteres, also dieser Digital Omnibus und da wird hauptsächlich nur drüber
gestritten, was der mit den Datenschutzbestimmungen macht.
Die anderen Themen sind unstrittiger, aber beim Datenschutz,
da ist natürlich auch ganz viel Lobbyingmacht dahinter.
Das haben wir auch in unserem Talk aufgezeigt. Da gibt es auch inzwischen gute
Belege zu sagen, Big Tech hat da viel mitgeschrieben,
weil die sind natürlich diejenigen, die am meisten profitieren,
wenn du mit Cookies arbeitest und dann gar nicht mehr unter die DSGVO fällst,
weil du kannst ja nicht identifizieren, wer das ist.
Du kannst sie zwar rausfiltern, aber du weißt den Namen nicht mehr.
So irrsinnige Konzepte liegen da ja gerade am Tisch und deswegen ist es gut,
dass jetzt auch bei den Mitgliedstaaten Widerstand laut wird.
Und das wird man auf jeden Fall sehr genau im Auge behalten müssen.
Und ja, die Kommission kommt da auf jeden Fall schon mal ins Schwitzen,
weil mit so viel Gegenwind hätte sie glaube ich auch nicht gerechnet.
Welche Staaten sind das dann, die sich da gegen wehren?
Also es gibt ein Ratsdokument, das sehr genau aufzeigt,
was jetzt in den ersten Aussprachen die Positionierung ist und nachdem sind
auf jeden Fall mal Belgien, Estland, Kroatien, Österreich, Niederlande ablehnend.
Und Frankreich bei einigen Fragen auch, insbesondere wenn es um Dinge geht,
wie darf die Kommission einseitig dann nochmal irgendwie mit Implementing Acts
Regeln erlassen oder sollte man das nicht eher bei den Regulierungsbehörden belassen.
Und wir haben bei dem Dokument noch nichts Konkretes zu Deutschland drinnen,
aber ich weiß aus den Fragen, die die Mitgliedstaaten an die Kommission geschickt
haben, dass Deutschland schon einige sehr gesalzene Fragen gestellt hat,
die auch in die Wunden stechen und die Kommission noch sehr ins Schwitzen gebracht haben.
Einfach so, wenn man den Vorschlag umsetzt, würde das nicht das,
das, das, das heißen und da hat es keine guten Antworten gegeben,
weil fachlich durchdacht ist das ja nicht, was die hier vorschlagen,
das ist sehr Lobby getrieben.
Ja, ist da irgendwas auch mit drin?
Es gab ja jetzt in letzter Zeit so diese Fälle, dass zum Beispiel dieses Do-Not-Track-Feature,
was zum Beispiel Apple in seinem Betriebssystem drin hat, dass ja dagegen auch
vorgegangen wird von den Lobbys, so in Italien vor allem und so.
Ist das irgendwie auch Teil dieses Pakets?
Das ist es. Do not track ist laut dem Kommissionsvorschlag, das ist einer der
wenigen guten Dinge, soll endlich rechtlich verpflichtend werden.
Es gibt diesen Standard ja schon lange.
Einige Browser wie Firefox haben den ja auch implementiert, aber viele Websites
haben sich nicht daran gehalten, sondern dir immer noch einen lästigen Cookie-Banner ins Gesicht gehalten,
anstatt auf dieses Do not track me Signal zu hören und einfach nicht zu überwachen.
Das will die Kommission rechtsverbindlich machen für Browser und für Webseitenbetreiber.
Auch da gibt es noch Lücken und ein paar Kritikpunkte, weil man will den neuen
Standard machen, anstatt den bestehenden, der über zehn Jahre abgehangen ist,
einfach rechtsverbindlich zu machen, was natürlich dann auch nächstes Jahr könnte
das schon gelten und für alle verpflichtend sein.
Oder in fünf Jahren haben wir einen Standard, den wir dann als verpflichtend
machen. Also ein großer Unterschied.
Und da gibt es aber natürlich wie zu erwarten Pushback und das Thema Cookies
generell soll ja auch neu geregelt werden.
Da wird es ein bisschen komplizierter, weil da geht es auch darum,
ob du eben auf fremden Geräten Dinge auslesen kannst. Das ist ja technisch das, was Cookies sind.
Und dafür braucht man, wenn es eben über ein für den Dienst notwendiges Maß
hinausgeht, die Zustimmung.
Deswegen haben wir diese leidigen Cookie-Banner und sind alle trainiert,
den Knopf zu finden, dass die weggehen.
Und da will man auch ran an die Regeln und sagen, hey, aber wenn das aggregierte
Zugriff-Statistiken sind oder Fragen der IT-Sicherheit, dann kannst du da vielleicht schon.
Also über diese Regeln wird noch gestritten, aber da ist jetzt,
sage ich auch mal, vielleicht eher ein sinnvoller Reformbedarf drin.
Ja, das ist aber alles noch Teil der Verhandlungen, da gibt es noch keine fixen
Sachen. Mehr dazu erzählen wir im Kongress-Talk.
Mhm. Es gibt ja die bisschen absurde Situation,
dass ja zum Beispiel jetzt Apple in seinen APIs für die Apps sozusagen den Zugriff
auf diese intern ja im Betriebssystem vorliegende Werbe-ID nicht den Apps gibt,
es sei denn, man macht da explizit Konsent.
Und jetzt wird ja Apple in verschiedenen Mitgliedstaaten deswegen verklagt,
weil das ja sozusagen aus kartellrechtlichen Gründen so nicht ginge.
So nach dem Motto, wenn Apple so eine ID hat, dann müssen sie die auch rausrücken.
Da frage ich mich jetzt, ob das sozusagen auch hier Teil der Debatte sein könnte.
Na, das ist glaube ich noch nicht Teil der logistischen Debatte rund um das
Gesetz, aber natürlich wird das darauf Auswirkungen haben.
Bei dem konkreten Fall bin ich mir jetzt auch nicht ganz so sicher.
Also würde Google jetzt im Chrome-Browser sich Tracking einbauen,
das nur sie verwenden könnten, hätte ich damit auch ein Problem.
Aber da sind wir wieder so in diesen klassischen Digital Markets Act Gefilden,
die so ein bisschen schwierig sind, inwieweit wir die Big Tech-Plattformen extra
an die Kantare nehmen müssen und inwieweit die sich öffnen müssen für andere.
Also darum geht dieses Gesetz explizit nicht.
Es ist keine Reform des Digital Markets Act, es geht nicht um Wettbewerbsrecht
per se, aber diese Bestimmungen sind ja woanders verankert und auf die Welt anwendbar.
Ja, dann mache ich gleich weiter, oder?
Ja, mach mal.
Netzneutralität, mein Lieblingsthema. Das wäre schon beendet.
Ich dachte ja auch. Ich habe gehofft, wir könnten das zu den Akten legen und
uns um andere Dinge kümmern, aber nein.
Und da geht es mir so wie Ralf Bendrath bei der Datenschutz-Grundverordnung.
Das ist so mein Baby, das war das erste Gesetz, an dem ich gearbeitet habe.
Und deswegen nehme ich es der Kommission auch sehr übel,
dass man mein Baby jetzt umschreiben will, denn Netzseutralität wird geschluckt
in ein neues Gesetz, in den Digital Networks Act und der wurde vor einer Woche,
glaube ich, vorgestellt am 21.
Jänner und dieses Gesetz hat es in sich. Es ist 300 Seiten stark und es ist
ein kompletter Rewrite des Rechtsrahmens für Telekommunikationsdienste in der EU.
Also das, was das Telekommunikationsgesetz ist in Mitgliedstaatenebene,
wird damit eigentlich ersetzt.
Es kommt ein EU-Gesetz, was nicht mehr eine Richtlinie ist, die ja immer erst
dann von den Mitgliedstaaten in nationales Recht überführt werden muss,
sondern eine Verordnung. Genau.
Es ist dann ein Text, der ist gültig in allen 27 EU-Ländern gleich.
Und nicht nur wird das, was heute im TKG ist, im Telekommunikationsgesetz hier,
subsummiert, sondern auch die Netzneutralität, die BEREC-Verordnung,
also das, was die Regulierungsbehörden regelt, Bnetz 1 in Deutschland,
RTR in Österreich, also jene Behörden, die der Deutschen Telekom auf die Finger hauen.
Wir haben auch es mit Spektrumsfragen zu tun, also wie man Radiospektrum vergibt.
Da will die EU natürlich mehr Zentralisierung und dergleichen mehr.
Also es ist wirklich ein bunter Blumenstrauß an Regeln, die hier vereinheitlicht werden.
Für uns ist natürlich besonders relevant, dass man die Netzneutralität nicht
nur umtopft, sondern gleich ordentlich Dinge abschneidet dabei und zwar ganz
essentielle Bestandteile,
ohne die wir wahrscheinlich um viele dieser jetzt über zehn Jahre lang gesicherten
Verpflichtungen und Schutzschranken umfallen werden.
Es wäre dann vielleicht wieder möglich, bezahlte Überholspuren zu machen,
Zero-Rating einzuführen.
Gerade im Hinblick auf 5G will die Kommission sich da selber auch nochmal die
Macht geben, die Regeln abzuändern.
Also statt den neutralen Behörden, die politisch unabhängig sind,
entscheidet dann die politisch besetzte EU-Kommission, die immer viel zu nah
an der Telekom-Industrie ist, wie diese Regeln ausschauen sollen.
Ja, das ist eine Parallele zwischen dem Digital Omnibus und der DSGVO-Reform
und hier in beiden Fällen will man nicht mehr die neutralen Regulierungsbehörden
entscheiden lassen, sondern auch lieber die Kommission selber hätte gerne die Macht zu sagen,
wo das Grundrecht aufhört, egal ob das jetzt Datenschutz oder Netzneutralität
ist und ab welchem Bereich,
Hierby Dragons dann ein unregulierter Bereich ist, wo die Firmen tun können, was sie wollen.
Gibt es denn eigentlich auf europäischer Ebene auch eine Regulierungsbehörde,
die im Prinzip mit den Nationalen zusammenarbeitet oder so?
Ja, die gibt es. Die haben wir hier auch schon oft erwähnt. Das ist BEREC.
The Body of European Regulators for Electronic Communications.
Ach das, alles klar.
Das ist der Zusammenschluss von den BNITS-As und RTRs und ACMs von all diesen nationalen Behörden.
Die leisten auch einen wirklich exzellenten Job. Ich bin sehr selten mit meinem
Lob, aber die haben es verdient, weil da die Arbeitsebene vor allem sich nicht lumpen lässt.
Die lassen die Fakten entscheiden, die hören
auch allen zu, die sind sehr faktengetrieben und das sind halt Nerds.
Das sind TechnikerInnen, Ökonominnen, JuristInnen, die da zusammenkommen und
über die Auslegung und Anwendung der Gesetze entscheiden.
Die sogenannten Barrett Guidelines waren hier ja schon oft Thema.
Das ist eben das Regelwerk, was aktuell regelt, wie wir Netzneutralität umsetzen.
Und da hat die Kommission kein Mitspracherecht. Das sind nur die Behörden,
die das entscheiden. Und das will man ändern.
Man will jetzt sagen, na na, die letzte Entscheidung liegt nicht mehr bei den
Behörden, sondern bei uns als Kommission.
Ich sehe gerade, also wir wollen irgendwie diesen European Electronic Communications Code,
die BEREC Regulation Radio Spectrum Policy Program und ein Quarteil von der
Open Internet Regulation in ein Paket packen.
Ganz genau.
Und in welcher davon ist sozusagen derzeit die Netzneutralität festgehalten
in der BEREC Regulation?
Nein, in der Open Internet Regulation. Die Open Internet Regulation 2015-21-20,
das ist das Gesetz, mit dem die Netzentralität in Europa erstmals verankert wurde.
2015 wurde das beschlossen, seit 2016 ist es in Kraft und dieses Regelwerk ist
eben, was jetzt auch die Basis liefert für das Verbot von Zero Rating,
von bezahlten Überholspuren,
dass wir aus Verträgen raus können, wenn der Internetprovider viel weniger Bandbreite
liefert, als er uns versprochen hat im Vertrag und in der Werbung.
Da ist ganz viel drinnen, auch was Internetzensur betrifft.
Wieso man nicht einfach nur auf Zuruf irgendwelche Websites sperren kann in Europa.
Wieso ein Internet-Shutdown nicht möglich oder zumindest nicht legal wäre in Europa.
All das ist dort geregelt und genau dieses Gesetz wird hier auch angegriffen.
Es gibt von uns...
21. Januar gibt es also jetzt den offiziellen Vorschlag jetzt für diese neue Regulierung.
Und ist daraus jetzt schon absehbar, dass irgendwas ganz Schlimmes kommt oder
ist das noch unklar alles?
Es ist wirklich leider die Entkernung der Netzseutralität befindet sich da drinnen.
Also es gibt eine Analyse von uns, die verlinken wir auch.
Und die Kernpunkte sind, dass eben Kernbestandteile rausfliegen,
die die die komplette Interpretation aufmachen von diesem Gesetz.
Die Artikel selber werden minimal geändert, aber die Erwägungsgründe,
der Beipackzettel, da wird von 19 Erwägungsgründen, werden 18 rausgestrichen.
Und damit ist auch ein klarer Wille des Gesetzgebers erkennbar,
dass man über diese Dinge umfällt.
Und in all den EuGH-Rechtsprechungen, zum Beispiel das Verbot von Zero-Rating
oder das Verbot davon, dass du am Ende von deinem Datenvolumen einzelne Dienste
noch durchlässt, aber andere nicht. Das war früher so eine Unterart von Zero-Rating.
All diese Gerichtsentscheidungen basieren großteils auf den Erwägungsgründen.
Und wenn die jetzt wegfallen, ist es leicht, zu Gericht zu gehen und zu sagen, hey, wait again.
We need to litigate this. Also das muss man dann neu verhandeln.
Da geht uns ein bisschen der Kompass abhanden.
Es wird auch so sein, die vorher angesprochenen Regulierungsbehörden,
BEREC, die bekommen einen Spion zugestellt.
Es ist nämlich so, dass die EU-Kommission sich ein neues Instrument überlegt
hat, und zwar das Office for Digital Networks, ODN.
Das ersetzt das alte Barrack-Office in Riga und dieses ODN.
Da wird die Kommission eine sehr starke Rolle dabei haben, sehr stark auch im
Management mitentscheiden.
Und dieses Office wird dann bei allen Arbeitsgruppen von Barrack mit am Tisch sitzen.
Und das wäre der Tod für eine faktische Diskussion.
Wenn du jemanden hast, der die ganze Zeit politische Agenda macht.
Und bei der EU-Kommission wissen wir halt auch, die liegen am laufenden Band
in Richtung Telekom-Industrie.
Bei den Marktuntersuchungen, die BEREC regelmäßig macht, zuletzt auch zum Beispiel
für den Zusammenschaltungsmarkt,
da sind die darauf angewiesen, dass wenn man was der Regulierungsbehörde erzählt,
dass das dort bleibt und nicht dann seinen Weg findet zu der Gegenseite.
Und das wäre dann einfach nicht mehr garantierbar.
Also damit kannst du gleich aufhören, weil der Kommission kann man,
zumindest wenn es um DigiConnect geht, bei diesen Fragen schon seit über zehn
Jahren nicht mehr vertrauen.
Und damit würden einfach die Regulierungsbehörden keinen vertrauensvollen,
neutralen Austauschraum mehr haben,
weil überall wäre die Kommission über ihrem Proxy mit am Tisch und das unterminiert
halt einfach die unabhängigen Regulierungsbehörden und damit auch die Rechtsstaatlichkeit.
Da hat ein politisches Gremium einfach nichts drin zu suchen.
Genau deswegen haben wir Regeln, dass Behörden unabhängig sein sollen,
gerade wenn sie mit der Aufrechterhaltung von Grundrechten oder Fragen des Wettbewerbs und so zu tun sind.
Und bei der Kommission fehlt diese Grenzziehung. Das ist historisch so gewachsen.
Bei den Wettbewerbsfragen war es als erstes so. DJ Competition war auch politisch
besetzt und dann macht es irgendwie Wettbewerbsregeln.
Beim Digital Services Act haben wir das nochmal verstärkt, weil da ist es jetzt
DJ Connect, die dann auch eine Strafe gegen X, gegen Twitter aussprechen zum
Beispiel. Ja, aber dieselbe Kommission verhandelt mit den USA gerade über die Zölle.
Also da vermischen sich Sphären, die ja eigentlich getrennt sein sollten,
aber das ist so eines der Grundprobleme der EU.
Das letzte Thema, das ist wirklich das Bitterste, sind die Netzgebühren.
Die haben wir ja auch schon oft hier diskutiert, Stichwort Fair Share.
Also es sollen auf einmal nicht mehr wir als Internetkunden für das Datenvolumen,
wofür wir eh schon zahlen, dann reicht das und dann sollen bitte alle Daten
aus der ganzen Welt auch zu uns transportiert werden.
Nein, man will es umdrehen, sodass an beiden Enden der Leitung jetzt Geld fließen muss.
Und wenn nicht für die Zusammenschaltung gezahlt wird, dann ist halt der Dienst,
den du nutzen willst, nur schlecht verfügbar.
Stichwort Netzbremse.de und die Beschwerde, die wir da mit der GFF und dem VZBV
und Professor Vanschewig gemeinsam gegen die Deutsche Telekom eingebracht haben.
Also das, was wir da ankreiden als Netzneutralitätsverstoß, soll mit dem Gesetz
möglich gemacht werden.
Das sind nur Voluntary Corporation Mechanisms, das ist nicht verpflichtend,
aber das soll hier auch sozusagen, zumindest wenn man das Gesetz aufmerksam
liest, da sind sich bisher alle Analysen einig, wird es auf das hinauslaufen.
Vor allem, es wird ja jetzt erst verhandelt, im Parlament haben wir Leute,
die sehr stark für sowas pochen, die sagen auch, hey, wir müssen Big Tech ja
zur Kasse bitten, was ja gar nicht das Thema ist eigentlich.
Es geht nicht um Big Tech versus Big Telco, sondern es geht um,
haben wir ein neutrales Netz, das alles übertragen muss.
Aber ja, da sind wir am Anfang der Verhandlungen. Wir haben noch kein Verhandlungsteam
vom Parlament zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt.
Wir hatten aber schon eine Aussprache im Plenum des Europaparlaments in Straßburg und die war am 21.
Jänner, also direkt am Tage, als das Gesetz rauskam. Und das war schon sehr...
Das war hoffnungsvoll fast. Also da gab es wirklich viele, die von sich aus
über Netzneutralität geredet hatten und nur ein Bruchteil der Abgeordneten,
die über Netzneutralität geredet haben, haben vorher bei mir angerufen.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall so, dass das Thema dort den Abgeordneten wichtig
ist und die auch verstehen, es geht hier um ein Gesetz, das den Menschen in Europa wichtig ist.
Netzneutralität aufheben, das hat nur einer bisher gemacht und das war Donald
Trump in seiner ersten Amtszeit, ist vielleicht nicht das beste Vorbild.
Ja, das könnte natürlich in der politischen Diskussion helfen.
Netzneutralität ist ja auch noch relativ jung.
Also es ist ja noch mal gar nicht so lange her, dass das jetzt so festgeklopft wurde.
Von daher könnte das ja vielen auch noch so ein bisschen, zumindest ein bisschen in Erinnerung sein.
Und das klingt ja nach hohem Widerstandspotenzial.
Was ist so deine Erwartung, über welchen Zeitraum so ein Gesetz dann letztlich umgesetzt werden soll?
Haben Sie das offiziell gesagt oder ist das jetzt quasi der erste Vorschlag der Kommission?
Dann wird ja noch viel Wasser, die Flüsse heruntergehen.
Also anders als die Omnibusse, die immer mit einem hohen Zeitdruck verhandelt
werden, ist das ein reguläres Gesetzgebungsverfahren.
Und nachdem wir hier von 300 Seiten Änderungsanträgen an zig Gesetzen sprechen,
die ganz viele InteressenträgerInnen auf den Plan rufen werden,
gehe ich von drei Jahren aus.
Also ich glaube, man will dieses Gesetz in dieser Gesetzgebungsperiode fertig
bekommen. Das sind noch vier Jahre.
Wir haben wahrscheinlich in den nächsten Wochen mal das Verhandlungsteam des Parlaments.
Bei den Mitgliedstaaten beginnen jetzt dann auch bald die ersten Aussprachen,
wo mal Reaktionen gesammelt werden.
Und das ist insofern auch relevant, weil da im Vorfeld auch schon Kritik kam,
nämlich so, hey, müssen wir das wirklich zentralisieren auf EU-Ebene?
Telekom-Regulierung, so Leitungen verbuddeln, das ist schon was sehr Lokales.
Und wenn du mal in Osteuropa warst und in Nordeuropa warst, dann weißt du,
wie unterschiedlich das ist.
Einfach nur, du siehst es am Stadtbild, ob diese Kabel an der Mauer entlang
getackert werden und du so wie in Bulgarien hunderte Netzwerkbetreiber hast,
die alle lokal sind und ein super schön dezentraler Markt.
Und in anderen Ländern, das zählt Deutschland dazu, eine starke Konzentration
und vielleicht ein paar virtuelle Operator.
Und ob da jetzt auch diese erhoffte Economy of Scale, dass weniger große Unternehmen
wirtschaftlicher sind als viele kleine, da haben viele ihre Zweifel.
Und natürlich diese Zentralisierung von der Aktion von Spektrum,
da geht es um Milliarden für die Mitgliedstaaten.
Das ist natürlich was, wo die Hauptstädte ungern auf diese Einnahmen verzichten
würden und jede weitere Harmonisierung auf EU-Ebene, die durchaus vielleicht sinnvoll ist,
wenn man sagt, man will, dass das koordiniert abläuft.
Natürlich dann auch die Angst, dass man langfristig um seine Pfunde umfällt, mit sich bringt.
Also da sind wir noch am Anfang und wir werden auf jeden Fall das Thema über
all die Jahre jetzt mit höchster Priorität weiterverfolgen.
Wir werden natürlich alles tun, um Netzfeutralität zu erhalten in ihrer jetzigen
Form und vielleicht auch noch bezüglich Netzgebühren werden wir auch in die Offensive gehen.
Also aus meiner Sicht, der Zusammenschaltungsmarkt hat zwar sehr gut funktioniert
in seiner unregulierten Form und ich finde es ein Wahnsinn, dass die EU-Kommission
überall sagt, Simplification,
Deregulation und wir müssen es den Unternehmen einfacher machen und dann haben
wir einen Markt, wo alle, die irgendeine Website haben,
jedes Online-Angebot ist da mittelbar oder unmittelbar drauf vertreten und jetzt
machen wir neue Regulierung dafür.
Ja, so frei war das dann auch nicht gemeint. Aber grundsätzlich muss ich sagen,
ich finde ja jetzt die Idee, eine einheitliche Verordnung zu haben,
dafür an sich ja durchaus unterstützenswert,
weil dann sind die Dinge mal klar,
müssen halt nur die richtigen Dinge drinstehen.
Ja, der Drops ist gelutscht. Also das wird eine Verordnung bleiben.
Das würde mich sehr wundern, wenn daran noch was gerüttelt wird.
Wie du sagst, es ist jetzt nur noch die Frage, was wird in diesem Gesetz drin entstehen?
Und da muss man das halt noch ein bisschen mitschapen.
Ganz genau. Das ist der Anfang von dieser langen Reise.
Logbuchnetzpolitik wird berichten. Und dann das dritte EU-Thema ist die gute alte Chat-Kontrolle.
Da gibt es nur ein kurzes Update, was mir Khaleesi mitgegeben hat.
Und zwar, Linus hat das ja schon sehr gut erklärt. Es gibt diese Interim Derogation.
Das ist ein Gesetz, was schon in Kraft ist.
Dass es im Moment erlaubt, so Filter nach kinderportografischen Inhalten zu
machen und diese Interim Derogation,
die sozusagen es zum Beispiel jetzt einem Dienst, der nicht verschlüsselt ist, erlaubt,
auf solche Inhalte zu scannen,
die würde ausraufen im April diesen Jahres, 2026.
Und deswegen gibt es da jetzt gerade starken Druck, dass man die verlängert
und das Gesetz ist schon eingebracht.
Es gibt ein Verhandlungsteam schon im Europaparlament, da wird Birgit Zippel,
ist glaube ich die Berichterstatterin von der SPD aus Deutschland und jetzt
im Februar wird es da an das Eingemachte gehen und das Ganze wird sehr wahrscheinlich durchgehen,
Weil natürlich den Status quo jetzt mal aufrecht zu erhalten,
ist eher ein No-Brainer.
Es gibt natürlich Stimmen, die sagen, nein, auch ein optionales Regime,
wo die Plattform entscheidet, ob sie die User ausspioniert, geht schon zu weit.
Aber das ist da jetzt sozusagen gerade in der Debatte.
Und parallel dazu wird aber schon die richtige Chatkontrolle sozusagen.
Das Gesetz, wo es um das verpflichtende Scannen von unserer privaten Kommunikation
geht und unter Umständen auch um das Ende von verschlüsselter Kommunikation.
Da sind wir in den Trilogverhandlungen, nachdem die Mitgliedstaaten sich auf
ihre Position geeinigt haben, noch unter der dänischen Ratspräsidentschaft.
Logbuch Netzpolitik hat berichtet und da beginnen jetzt natürlich auch die Verhandlungen
in die entscheidenden Phasen zu gehen.
Da kann ich jetzt gerade noch nicht zu viele Inside-Stories erzählen,
aber was man jetzt schon da sieht, ist, dass Altersverifikation ein großes Thema ist.
Darauf kommen wir nahe sicherlich auch nochmal zu sprechen, aber ich glaube,
da sollten wir vielleicht ein bisschen reinzoomen, weil das war in der Sendung
ja auch immer wieder mal Thema.
Australien hat so etwas, Frankreich hat so etwas, Großbritannien hat da Gesetze erlassen.
Auch Griechenland hat einen sehr komischen Weg gewählt. Aber wir haben jetzt
überall diese Mindestalter für Social Media. Ähnlich wie bei Zigaretten und Alkohol.
Soziale Netzwerke sollen erst ab einem gewissen Alter erlaubt sein.
Auch in Österreich gibt es gerade wieder Debatten dazu.
Ich war die Woche in der Zeit im Bild 2 in unserer Tagesschau zu dem Thema.
Und ich habe die große Befürchtung, dass...
Es wenig Chancen gibt, das noch zu verhindern.
Wenn man sich die Reden im Plenum des Europaparlaments anschaut,
dann sind es eigentlich nur die rechtsextremen Fraktionen, die da klar dagegen sind.
Es gibt bei den Grünen, bei den Sozialdemokraten, bei den Liberalen einzelne
Abweicher, die sagen, na, das ist eine schlechte Idee, aber der Großteil dieser
Parteien und der Stimmen ist dafür, das zu machen,
auch wenn es den meisten komplett egal ist, wie es technisch umsetzbar ist,
Was natürlich ein Wahnsinn wäre, weil es auf eine Identifizierungspflicht im
Netz und eine neue Kontrolleinfrastruktur hinauslaufen würde.
Die Erfahrungen in Australien und in Frankreich, ich glaube,
da muss man jetzt genau hinschauen, was man daraus lernen kann.
Vielleicht sind das mahnende Beispiele, um diese Idee doch noch einzufangen.
Aber als jemand, der jetzt lang genug in der Netzpolitik bei dem Trauerspiel
zuschauen muss, sage ich dir, das hat schon einen starken Zug zum Tor,
dass da jetzt zumindest in irgendeiner Form so ein Gesetz kommen wird.
Ich glaube kleinere Länder wie Österreich, da kriegen wir es verhindert,
aber bei der EU sollte die sich dazu entscheiden, dann regulatorisch hat sie den Spielraum.
Ein schlechtes Gesetz kriegt man vielleicht beim EuGH zu Fall,
aber es wird schwierig das noch abzuwenden, zumindest komplett.
Also die Altersverifikation, nicht die Chatkontrolle.
Ja, die Chatkontrolle, da glaube ich schon die verpflichtende Speicherung auf
jeden Fall. Da glaube ich haben wir gute Karten, den Kampf den können wir gewinnen.
Ja, ihr habt ja zur Altersverifikation auch, glaube ich, einen Vorschlag gemacht,
um da diese Debatte noch mit zu beeinflussen.
Genau, das ist vom November letzten Jahres.
Ich wollte es nur kurz erwähnen und durchaus auch kritisch hier diskutieren
und würde mich über Feedback dazu freuen.
Wir verlinken den Vorschlag. Es ist sicherlich wert, den auch zu lesen.
Aber wenn ich ihn zusammenfassen muss, würde ich sagen, in der Nutshell,
wir versuchen einen Weg aufzuzeigen, wie man so ein Social-Media-Verbot machen
könnte, ohne Identifizierungspflicht,
ohne Identitätsdokumente, ohne digitale Identität.
Nämlich einfach, indem man sagt, die Geräte von Kindern und Jugendlichen sind
im Netz als solche klassifiziert.
Der Vorteil ist, Eltern wissen, wie alt ihre Kinder sind, LehrerInnen auch.
Das heißt, es müsste eigentlich nur, wenn das Gerät eingestellt wird,
das Teil der Parental Controls festgelegt werden, dies ist das Gerät von Alterskohorte so und so.
Und dann würde das nach unserem Vorschlag über den W3C-Standard auch übers Web
transportiert werden, sodass dann eben auch eine Webseite, die für diese Altersgruppe
in diesem Land illegal ist, sich selbst sperrt.
Würde sie das nicht tun, dann wäre das natürlich auch was, wo man mit Rechtsdurchsetzung,
mit Klagen, vielleicht sogar mit Haftung vorgehen könnte, sodass dann eben nicht
mehr dieser ich bin eh 16, 18, was auch immer Knopf ausreichen würde.
Dafür müsste das Ganze natürlich rechtsverbindlich sein.
Wir sehen ja schon ähnliche Age-Signals im Moment in den App-Stores.
Da gibt es ja auch schon Gesetze, auch in den USA, in manchen Bundesstaaten dazu.
Und als jemand, der lange mit digitaler Identität schon arbeitet,
wäre das wirklich der Super-GAU, wenn wir hier mit irgendwelchen Identitätslösungen operieren.
Weil das Missbrauchspotenzial ist damit so viel größer. Und das heißt ja,
alle müssen sich ständig ausweisen, wenn sie das Netz nutzen.
Wohingegen der Vorschlag, den wir vorsehen, sieht halt nur so,
dass die Geräte von Kindern und Jugendlichen, bei denen ändert sich was,
um mehr Agency an die Eltern zu geben.
Damit bleibt auch diese Entscheidungsgewalt in den Familien und geht nicht zum Staat.
Und für alle anderen Geräte und User bleibt alles gleich. Das wäre der Vorschlag in der Nutshell.
Ja, ist vor allem technologisch auch durchaus sinnvoll umzusetzen.
Sicherlich nicht unumgehbar, aber darum geht es ja auch nicht.
Und ja, macht total Sinn, weil das ist halt wirklich Quatsch.
Man stellt sich jetzt mal vor, so wie wir irgendwie mit Cookie-Bannern beballert
werden, müssten wir die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Ausweisfunktionen betätigen,
um irgendwelche Inhalte zu sehen.
Da wären wir des Lebens ja nicht mehr froh.
Absolut. Und wenn es heute das Alter ist, es könnte morgen irgendein anderes
Kriterium sein, anhand dessen du den Zugang regulierst.
Und es gibt da lösbare Probleme und unlösbare Probleme.
Es wäre technisch machbar, das unlinkable, unobservable, zero knowledge zu bauen,
sodass du halt wirklich da keine Gefahr hast für das Individuum.
Aber es bleibt natürlich immer noch,
Die soziale Frage, weil nicht alle Menschen haben digitale Identitäten,
haben überhaupt ein Smartphone, um solche auszuführen. Nicht alle haben Dokumente.
Und auch wenn das System technisch so funktionieren würde, ich glaube,
die Renitenz wäre zu groß.
Also du kriegst nicht die Leute dazu, dass sie eine staatliche ID verwenden,
bevor sie Porno schauen. Das wird nie passieren.
Und damit wird es auch massiv Umgehungsmöglichkeiten geben.
Und ich meine, wo sind wir jetzt?
Wegen iranischen Protesten installieren sich alle Snowflake,
um den Menschen dort unzensiertes Internet zu erlauben.
Und dann brauchen wir hier auch bei Tor, um noch irgendwie soziale Netzwerke zu verwenden.
Also ja, es ist ein schwieriges Thema.
Ja, vor allem, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das in dieser Debatte so eine Rolle spielt,
aber wenn ich mal kurz drüber nachdenke.
Dieses Identität nachweisen bedeutet im Zweifelsfall ja auch,
und das ist ja das Kernproblem, dass man eigentlich mehr Informationen präsentiert als nötig.
Und wenn die, weil mindestens ein Name oder so etwas fällt dabei ab und je nachdem,
wie gut diese Identitätsfunktionen umgesetzt sind oder wie legal sie umgesetzt sind,
kann natürlich noch sehr viel mehr Daten dabei übertragen werden.
Welche die jetzt letztlich wirklich herangezogen, also ob zum Beispiel nur das
Alter herangezogen wird, ist,
dann schon mal so eine Frage. Also mindestens müsste so ein Ausweisvorgang in
der Lage sein, da schon eine Datenreduktion zu betreiben, weil wenn das nicht
so ist, also wenn es jetzt wirklich so nach dem Motto,
du möchtest jetzt hier Alkohol kaufen im Supermarkt, sag mal deinen Personalausweis,
dann zeige ich meinen Personalausweis, da stehen ja auch noch ganz viele andere Sachen drin,
dann kann es ja sehr gut sein, dass dann eben der entsprechende Dienstleister
auf Basis ganz anderer Informationen, die er in dem Moment enthalten hat,
dir diesen Dienst,
nicht im gleichen Maße oder überhaupt bereitstellt. Preise ändern sich,
weil man auf einmal auf Basis des Namens oder der Adresse der Meinung ist,
wäre es jetzt irgendwie besonders reich.
Oder aus anderen Gründen werden bestimmte Dienste dann gar nicht mehr angeboten
oder nur noch eingeschränkt oder langsam oder was auch immer.
Also das ist definitiv ein großes Problem. Und mindestens muss man eben sicherstellen,
Wenn das im Moment einer Verifikation an der Stelle, wo sie nötig ist,
dann auf jeden Fall darauf geachtet wird, dass ausschließlich die eigentliche
Frage beantwortet wird.
In dem Fall die Frage, bist du alt genug?
Und mehr nicht, nicht wie alt bist du oder wann hast du Geburtstag?
Das ist ja dann alles schon wieder einen Schritt zu weit.
Und das darf man, wenn das das Ziel sein soll, auf keinen Fall den Unternehmen
überlassen, wie das Australien gemacht hat, die einfach diese heiße Kartoffel
der technischen Umsetzung den Firmen umgehängt haben.
Und da wissen wir einfach, die sammeln gerne Daten, umso mehr je besser.
Und das führt dann zu den erwartbaren Leaks von Passdaten, wie wir sie auch
schon gesehen haben in den letzten Jahren, weil natürlich da,
wo Identifikationsdaten ankommen, können die auch wegkommen.
Und wenn das beglaubigte Daten sind, sprich signierte Informationen über die
Identität, dann ist der Schaden umso größer.
Das ist ja auch ein Thema, diese Deniability, die wir bei IDAS leider nicht gelöst haben.
Und das ist ein super komplexes Thema und die Art, wie es diskutiert wird,
ist aber, ah mein Gott, die armen Kinder, Social Media ist so gefährlich,
wir müssen jetzt unbedingt sofort, was für die Kinder tun.
Und dann sobald du in Österreich ist der Vorschlag 14, ja sobald du 14 bist,
bist du aber erst recht wieder auf diesen sozialen Netzwerken.
Also das ist auch keine gute Medienbildung und es ist es versteckt auch so das
reale Problem, was wir zu lösen hätten, nämlich die Rechtsdurchsetzung, die nicht passiert.
Wir haben die DSGVO, die hat ein Mindestalter nämlich in Form der Geschäftsfähigkeit, wenn du.
Unter 13, 14, 15 bist, das ist nationalstaatlich geregelt, dann müssten die
Eltern zustimmen, sonst kannst du keine AGBs abnicken eigentlich.
Hat niemanden interessiert über all die Jahre. Da haben wir nie Strafen verhängt zum Beispiel.
Da könnte man große, große Strafen rausgeben gegen TikTok, die ja hauptsächlich
irgendwie minderjährige User haben.
Und das sind alles Themen, wo die Politik natürlich das tut,
was in Umfragen gut klingt, nämlich irgendwas für die Kinder,
aber dem Problem Herr zu werden und diese toxischen sozialen Netzwerke endlich
mal an die Kantare zu nehmen oder eben die dezentralen Alternativen zu befördern,
Stichwort Fediverse und Digital Independence Day,
das wären ja alles Dinge, die man tun könnte, nur die dauern viel länger, die sind mühsamer.
Und diese ganze Debatte ist mir viel zu faktenfern.
In Österreich ist es ja zum Beispiel auch so, dass man nur immer von Social Media Verbot spricht.
Also da wäre da Mastodon und Blue Sky auch verboten und vielleicht andere sehr
gute und nicht toxische soziale Netzwerke,
weil man irgendwie diese nicht näher definierte Technologie sozialer Netzwerke verbieten will.
Also da wird wirklich, es ist eine schlimme Debatte, aber ich befürchte,
wir können uns ihr nicht mehr entziehen und sie wird für 2026 auch prägend sein.
Ich würde sie noch anfangen hier Podcasts zu verbieten. Guck mal denn da hin.
Ha, gute Idee.
Was würdest du denn für ein Einstiegsalter empfehlen für Logbuch-Netzpolitik?
Ja, was wäre denn deine Qualifikation? Also ab welchem Alter würdest du Logbuch-Netzpolitik denn zulassen?
Was ist unsere jüngste Hörerin?
Das würde mich auch interessieren, was ist die jüngste Hörerin?
Ich würde ja sagen, alle, die sie so halbwegs beisammen haben.
Also ich meine, wenn du in der Lage bist, einen klaren Gedanken zu fassen,
dann kannst du ja auch zuhören.
Okay, spannend.
Das kann schon relativ früh stattfinden. Es gibt ja auch schon so achtjährige
Schachgroßmeister und so, die dürfen ja alle gerne einschalten.
Ja, digitale Identität, ein Thema, was natürlich jetzt auch nochmal richtig
Feuer kriegt durch die ganze digitale Souveränitätsdebatte,
da brennt jetzt auch ein kleines Feuer in den Niederlanden, Denn dort gibt es ja,
weil das ja so ein Land ist, was so ein bisschen in der Zukunft lebt,
im Gegensatz zu unseren Ländern,
gibt es halt einen Dienst, der dort auch sehr verbreitet ist,
aber eben von einem privaten Anbieter namens DigiD,
also D-I-G-I-D.
Und das ist so theoretisch nicht der einzige, aber wo so praktisch der Standard
für Identifikation online insbesondere, wenn es um staatliche Dienste geht.
Also wenn man Innenministerium, Justizministerium, niederländische Polizei.
Staatliche Inkassobehörde für Bußgelder, die ganze Kommune Amsterdam,
also wenn man da in irgendeiner Form was tun will und sich ausweisen muss,
dass man jetzt hier auch berechtigt ist, die jeweiligen Informationen zu erhalten oder zu ändern,
dann ist der Standard halt dieses DigiD.
Und DigiD ist wiederum ein Produkt des Unternamens Solvinity.
Und Solvinity ist zwar ein niederländisches Unternehmen,
allerdings haben die Aktionäre jüngst einer Übernahme dieses Unternehmens Unternehmens
durch das Unternehmen Kindrill Netherlands zugestimmt.
Problem, Kyndryl ist eine US-Firma, also es ist sozusagen die Tochter einer,
die niederländische Tochter einer US- Holding,
die weltweit verteilt ist, so und damit gilt dann quasi nach Kauf letzten Endes
vor allem die US-amerikanische Gesetzeslage und jetzt kannst du dir vorstellen,
dass gerade alle rumrennen, wie die aufgescheuchten Hühner,
weil sie jetzt alarmiert sind und auch der Staat ist dort schon alarmiert und
das sogenannte Investitionsprogramm Das Prüfungsamt BTI hat also jetzt hier
Ermittlungen eingeleitet,
ob sie denn jetzt hier in irgendeiner Form einschreiten müssen und ob es eine
Basis gibt, das zu verhindern, weil es natürlich auch in den Niederlanden so
Vorbehalte gibt bezüglich Staatssicherheit etc. und so weiter.
Ja, also lustigerweise sind wohl Systeme auf Basis von Digity gerade auch in
Amsterdam eingeführt worden, damit sie irgendwie ihre Abhängigkeit von Microsoft reduzieren können.
Ja, das geht dann halt alles noch einen Schritt weiter und zeigt einfach auch
sehr schön, welche Kaskaden das haben kann.
Generell ist ja so der Verkauf von Unternehmen an irgendwelche ausländischen
Konzerne in den letzten Jahren durchaus ein populäres Ding gewesen.
Da geht es auch gar nicht mal immer nur in Richtung USA, sondern teilweise auch
in Richtung China und andere Länder.
Und solange das halt dann nicht mehr in der EU ist, hast du natürlich ein echtes Problem.
Ja, also das ist gerade etwas, was dort diskutiert wird und ich denke mal,
ähnliche Diskussionen stehen demnächst hier auch in Deutschland und wahrscheinlich
auch in Österreich an, weil es natürlich zahlreiche Verpflichtungen gibt.
Wofür spricht das? Das spricht dafür, dass wenn man solche Lösungen macht.
Dann sollte man halt zusehen, dass man das auf Basis von Standards macht und
dass man irgendwie zur Implementierung dieser Standards staatliche Infrastruktur
schafft, also digitale staatliche Infrastruktur.
Weil mir kann ja jetzt keiner erzählen, dass es zum Beispiel für die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland oder auch für Österreich in irgendeiner Form ein grundsätzliches
Problem sein sollte, eine solche Infrastruktur bereitzustellen.
Weil für mich gehört das halt genauso dazu wie das Bauen von Behördengebäuden.
Also wenn du einen Staat haben willst, der soll betrieben werden,
dann hast du da auch deinen Pförtner, da hast du da deine Mitarbeiter und entsprechende Strukturen,
Besucher zu empfangen und die können sich ja auch ausweisen und das Ganze muss
natürlich dann auch digital funktionieren,
ohne dass man jetzt anfängt irgendwelche Party Security Services da vorne an den Eingang zu stellen.
Also, ja, diese Diskussion wird weitergehen.
Spannend. Also ich glaube, das ist sicherlich ein Thema, wo viel zu wenig Aufmerksamkeit
drauf liegt, was in Europa alles aufgekauft wird.
Gerade eben kritische Infrastruktur und digitale Identitätssysteme zählen das sicherlich dazu.
Aber ja, du hast recht, offene dezentrale Standards sind ein Weg,
wie du diese Abhängigkeit von vornherein ausschließt.
Und ich glaube, bei manchen Kerntechnologien sollte man da auf jeden Fall drauf achten.
Aber dann noch so Fragen wie Vergabe, ja, also dass wir zum Beispiel keine EU-Bevorzugung
haben auf dem Vergabemarkt, dass man da einfach nicht schaut,
ist es jetzt irgendwie nicht auch ein europäischer Arbeiter vielleicht besser,
als jetzt schon wieder Microsoft einzusetzen für diese Dinge.
Und ja, ich bin gespannt, wie das auch geht. Und auf der Webseite von DigiD
hast du schon irgendwie so einen großen Banner, wo sie sagen so,
ja, hier, wir erklären, das ist ja alles gar nicht so schlimm.
Also da dürften einige Leute gerade ins Schwitzen kommen.
Ja, und ich meine, ich halte das für so einen No-Brainer, weil wir haben ja
immer noch so ein bisschen diese Kultur, dass man, dass so der Start ...
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen meine Interpretation oder Sicht der Dinge.
Also das ist immer so meine Wahrnehmung.
Also man hat ja keine Nähe zu diesem ganzen Digitalen. Das merken wir ja immer, immer wieder.
Das ändert sich jetzt so langsam, aber das hätte sich halt auch schon vor 10
oder 20 Jahren ändern dürfen, müssen.
Und weil diese Nähe nicht da ist, ist ja auch immer so diese Hilflosigkeit.
Also wir hatten das in den Themen jetzt, die wir schon heute besprochen haben,
immer so dieses, ja, wir wissen gar nicht, wie wir das machen sollen.
Wir wissen nicht, wie wir digitale
Identität, Altersverifikation umsetzen sollen oder dieses und jenes.
Das können wir alles nicht. Das ist ja alles so kompliziertes Zeug.
Lass mal mal die Unternehmen machen. Die kennen sich da besser mit aus,
dann passt das schon irgendwie.
Wahl, Software. Also es gibt so viele Beispiele, wo wir das hier schon gehabt
haben und auch immer wieder Beispiele sind,
wo es dann auch einfach schief geht oder Missbrauch vorliegt oder beides und
man sich immer fragt, warum macht denn der Staat das nicht?
Aber der Staat kommt halt irgendwie nicht auf die Idee, weil er natürlich auch
weiß, weil er diese Kompetenz gar nicht hat.
Das ist natürlich dann jetzt so eine Schlange, die sich selber in den Schwanz
beißt, weil wenn man halt nie anfängt in irgendeiner Form eine Kompetenz aufzubauen,
dann hat man sie halt auch nicht, wenn man sie braucht.
Und so wie man ein Militär auch in Friedenszeiten trainiert,
muss man auch mal dafür sorgen, dass man einfach so im Digitalen,
mindestens ja mal auf Forschungsbasis Sachen betreibt.
Ja, also es ist ja noch nicht mal so, dass in irgendeiner Form für so eine fortlaufende
Kompetenz gesorgt wird.
Klar, es gibt so Wissenschaftsräte, Beiräte etc., aber es wird einfach noch.
Zu wenig daran gearbeitet, sich generell fit zu halten in diesem Bereich,
dass wenn neue Herausforderungen kommen,
dass man die dann auch aus eigenen Ressourcen betreiben kann.
Und das, klar, das wird Geld kosten, das ist auch schwierig sowas aufzubauen,
weil wir natürlich auch immer die Situation haben,
dass der Staat im Zweifelsfall weniger Geld bezahlt als die freie Wirtschaft
für totale Experten, aber das Problem hast du ja eigentlich in allen Bereichen
so und da hat ein Staat ja mit,
den Vorzügen eines Beamtentums und so. Es ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt ein Staat nichts zu bieten hätte.
Du wirst jetzt vielleicht nicht die Top-Heads kriegen, die dir irgendwie an
einem Wochenende Netflix aufbauen, aber das brauchst du ja auch gar nicht,
weil diese ganzen Dinge, ich meine digitale Identität,
wie lange diskutieren wir dieses Thema schon in Hacker-Kreisen?
Doch mindestens seit 20, 30 Jahren.
Also das ist einfach Login und im Internet und HTTPS und worüber wir,
also die grundlegenden Sachen, ja Leute verschlüsselt mal euren Scheiß,
man kann hier auf jeder Konferenz alle Passwörter mitlesen, es sind doch immer dieselben Themen und,
schon als der Personalausweis.
Eingeführt wurde, der mit Chip, sind diese Probleme ja tatsächlich auch schon
mal gelöst worden zumindest zum Teil.
Also es ist ja so, dass es auch nicht so, dass da jetzt gar nichts da wäre,
aber man darf es halt nicht einfach gleich wieder fallen lassen wie eine heiße
Kartoffel, wenn das Thema vom Tisch ist, sondern man muss eben konsequent das aufbauen.
Ich habe da noch so ein bisschen meine Probleme, jetzt haben wir ja mal so ein
Digitalministerium in Deutschland, ich bin noch nicht so hundertprozentig davon
überzeugt, dass das BDSM genau, das BDSM und,
Denen muss man Zeit geben, weil ein neues Ministerium aufbauen und so weiter,
Leute einstellen, Kompetenz und dann auch mal Ergebnisse.
Das wird wahrscheinlich auch so eine Legislatur dauern, aber dann irgendwann
müssen da auch mal Ergebnisse kommen. Wie sieht das eigentlich in Österreich aus?
Ach, wir haben ein Digitalisierungsstaatssekretariat, das immer so die heiße
Kartoffel ist und meistens sind es irgendwelche jungen männlichen Günstlinge
der Konservativen, die das anführen.
Und wir hatten einmal eine Person, die wirklich kompetent war,
also die zumindest Technik verstanden hat,
die ist aber jetzt nicht mehr auf diesem Posten, weil sie sich politisch verkalkuliert
hat und dachte, sie könnte in die Landespolitik wechseln.
Jetzt ist sie bei einem großen Telekom-Betreiber.
Der Nachfolger ist aus einer der dynastischen, konservativen Familien,
die in der ÖVP schon seit Jahrzehnten den Ton angeben und macht lustige TikTok-Videos
und sitzt in selbstfahrenden Autos und ist jetzt auch für Altersverifikation,
muss unbedingt kommen.
Österreich muss hier ganz dringend noch vor dem Schulstart im Herbst was tun.
Und er ist zuständig für die ID Austria und mitverantwortlich dafür,
dass das aktuelle System in Österreich so veraltet ist und kaum noch funktioniert.
Also sie sind gut im Marketing, das ist Digitalisierung für die Politik auch.
Es ist was, um sich zu schmücken, aber es wird nicht verstanden als etwas, wo man deliveren muss.
Also digitale Souveränität ändert jetzt so ein bisschen etwas,
weil sie da zum ersten Mal auch schon merken so, okay, eigentlich haben wir
auch Geld, das wir einsetzen können über Investitionen und da können wir lokal
auch Dinge mitgestalten.
Und ich frage mich immer, bis einer mal auf die Idee kommt, so ja.
Anschließend an das, was du vorher gesagt hast, ja, vielleicht hat der Staat
nicht immer selber schon jetzt die Ressourcen dafür, diese Dinge selber zu bauen.
Aber gut, wenn ich ein Unternehmen beauftrage, wieso beauftrage ich die dann
dazu, dass sie etwas bauen, was ihr Intellectual Property bleibt?
Ich kann denen auch sagen, ja, entwickle mir einen offenen Standard,
entwickle mir eine Open Source Code Basis und baue die Community rundherum und
mache das gemeinsam mit anderen, sodass Public Money, Public Code, ganz einfach.
Ja, also man kann ja Unternehmen einsetzen, aber es darf ihnen das nicht gehören
am Ende, was mit Steuergeld finanziert wurde.
Ja, das ist auch so ein Punkt. Also in der Übergangsphase, wo man quasi auf
externe Kompetenz angewiesen ist, müssen solche Systeme etabliert werden,
dass das nicht gleich verloren geht.
Und wenn die Unternehmen das dann nicht machen wollen, selber schuld.
Aber mittelfristig muss das dann eben auch in den eigenen Betrieb übernommen werden.
Da kann der Staat ja dann auch die Startups kaufen.
Ja, ja. Und auch Anteile und so. Ich meine, es gibt ja alle möglichen Konstruktionen.
Verstaatlichung mal anders.
Es wäre so viel Schönes, denkbar, Tim.
Naja. Gut.
Wie schaffst du jetzt diesen Übergang?
Es könnte so viel Schönes geben. Es sei denn, die Politik denkt mal drüber nach,
was sie wieder an Zombies aus der Schublade herausholen kann.
Zombie der Woche, ihr werdet es schon ahnen, ist die Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Wir haben, weil ja die rot-schwarze Koalition in Deutschland das sich mal wieder
in den Koalitionsvertrag geschrieben hat, wie soll es auch anders sein,
einen neuen Vorschlag für eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung unter dem schönen Namen
Entwurf eines Gesetzes zur Einführung einer IP-Adressspeicherung und Weiterentwicklung
der Befugnisse zur Datenerhebung im Strafverfahren.
Eine dreimonatige Speicherung von IP-Adressen bei Internetdiensten,
also bei Internetzugangsdiensteanbietern.
Also ihr wählt euch ein und die zugeteilte IP-Adresse soll dann eben für drei
Monate gespeichert werden. Die alte Leier.
Genau, das ist jetzt als Referentenentwurf wieder in den Gesetzesprozess reingeworfen worden.
Es ist so ein bisschen unklar, was hier eigentlich nennenswert anders ist als
bei den ganzen anderen Varianten, die wir schon hatten und die vom Verfassungsgericht
ohnehin schon wieder verboten worden sind.
Das wird sich zeigen.
Außerdem, da kann ich jetzt aber zu den Details nicht so viel sagen,
werden auch die Befugnisse zur Datensicherung und zur Funkzellenabfrage gesetzlich
neu geregelt und erweitert.
Da können wir uns schon etwa vorstellen, was da drinstehen soll.
Naja, also...
Und das ist ja auch nicht nur jetzt ein nationales Ding in Deutschland,
sondern es gibt ja auch auf europäischer Ebene eine neue Vorratsdatenspeicherungsdiskussion, richtig?
Ganz genau, Stichwort Protect EU. Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist auf der Agenda
wahrscheinlich erst nächstes Jahr, 2027,
dass das kommt, aber da ist man sich nie so sicher.
Und es gibt die dazugehörigen Arbeitsgruppen, wo auch noch offen ist,
also das hört sich jetzt, wenn ich dich richtig verstanden habe,
in Deutschland so an, dass es wirklich nur die IP-Adressen von dem Internetzugangsdienst sind.
Du hast ja immer noch auch die Telefonvorratsdatenspeicherung,
wobei natürlich heutzutage wenig telefoniert wird, aber das wäre historisch auch dabei.
Und in manchen EU-Ländern, wie Dänemark zum Beispiel, ist es wirklich auch für die Sessions.
Das heißt, du hast dann wirklich auch, wohin wurde eine Verbindung aufgemacht,
was natürlich dann unheimlich tiefgreifende Überwachung ist,
woran du auch das komplette Kommunikationsverhalten ja anhand dieser Metadaten ablesen kannst.
Und manchmal gibt es dann auch noch die Varianten, dass du bei den Diensteanbietern
nochmal Speicherverpflichtungen verankerst.
Also da ist sicherlich ganz viel Schlimmes, was noch in der Pipeline ist.
Ich stelle mir auch immer die Sinnfrage, weil Quick Freeze hat sich doch wirklich bewährt.
Vor allem ist es, das sind Gesetze, die dann auch für Gericht halten und nicht
wie die Vorratsdatenspeicherung einkassiert werden. und ich verstehe nicht,
wieso die Politik diesen Fetisch nicht los wird, das immer wieder zu fordern.
Weil ihnen einfach nichts Besseres einfällt, also es ist einfach so.
Ja, aber es ist halt auch das Gegenteil von Datenschutz und von europäischen
Werten, wenn du sagst, ich überwache halt alle auf Vorrat,
unabhängig davon, ob es einen Verdacht gibt, das ist das Ende der Unschuldsvermutung
und damit bist du immer im Konflikt mit den Grundrechten und das ist auch immer eine Datenbasis,
die so gefährlich ist, wenn das abhanden kommt, das liegt ja bei den Unternehmen,
bevor es der Staat anfragt.
Das heißt, in Österreich ist uns das zum Glück bisher erspart geblieben.
Seit der Abschaffung 2014 hat es nur einmal 2015 ein Politiker sich getraut,
nach den Anschlägen von Charlie Hebdo das zu fordern.
Und der Backlash war so stark, dass sogar die Journalisten ihm gesagt haben,
das ist aber verfassungswidrig, dass sie es seitdem nicht mehr probiert haben.
Aber ich mache mir keine Hoffnungen, dass ein Magnus Brunner,
der Innenkommissar der EU ist, hier nicht mitmachen wird bei diesen schlechten Ideen.
Also ich hoffe, dass die Kräfte in Deutschland das verhindert bekommen.
Ja, und es gibt ja auch auf EU-Ebene jetzt auch schon Ideen da,
gleich so die Messenger auch noch mit reinzunehmen.
Also WhatsApp, Telegram, Signal, SRIMA und Co.
Also das wird dann eh nochmal so eine Chat-Kontrolle 2.0-Diskussion werden,
glaube ich. Schauen wir mal, was kommt.
Ja, gleiche Identifizierungspflicht bei den Messengern, die bei der Chatkontrolle
diskutiert wird und dann noch die Vorratsdatenspeicherung bei den Messengern,
dass du auch genau weißt, wer wann mit wem kommuniziert hat.
Und dann würde es mich wundern.
In Österreich ist so bestimmt alles viel besser, oder?
But why?
Nein.
Also die nächste Meldung aus Österreich ist, dass wir gerade ein Thema diskutieren,
genannt Innenstadtüberwachung.
Da geht es um Verkehrsberuhigung. Es geht darum, dass die Innenstädte in Österreich
autofrei sein sollen, aber nicht komplett. Ein paar Autos sollen schon noch rein.
Die Vorschläge sind dann so vor, dass die Anrainer noch rein dürfen,
die Zulieferer, die Hotelgäste, die Leute, die ins Parkhaus fahren,
die nach 30 Minuten wieder draus sind, die Taxis, die Einsatzfahrzeuge,
die Busse und die Liste ist lang.
Wie kann man sowas kontrollieren, diese komplizierten Regeln?
Na ja, man macht einfach Hubschrauber-Einsatz.
Hubschrauber-Einsatz.
Fast Kameras, die hängen ganz statisch über der Straße und erkennen alle Kennzeichen
und strafen dann, wenn man irgendwo reinfährt, wo man nicht reinfahren darf.
Es sind aber sehr kreativ. Sie planen zum Beispiel auch, dass man diese Kameras
dann in Fußgängerzonen aufstellt.
Sollte dort ein Auto reinfahren, dass man das auch strafen kann.
Wegen Terror wahrscheinlich. Auch.
Das Argument hat noch keiner verwendet. Bringen Sie nicht auf Ideen.
Entschuldigung.
Da gibt es ein Gesetz, die Novelle der Straßenverkehrsordnung,
die war bis vor ein paar Monaten in Begutachtung und die Begutachtung war gesalzen,
sehr zu unseren Gunsten.
Wir sind bei diesem Thema seit 2021 natürlich laute Kritiker,
weil wir mögen keine Videoüberwachung. Erst recht nicht in Zeiten von Gesichtserkennung
und automatisierte Strafen aufgrund von Bilderkennung könnten auch irgendwie ein Problem sein.
Auf jeden Fall ist das Thema lange Zeit nur in Expertinnenkreisen diskutiert
worden und jetzt wird es langsam lauter.
Wir haben Rückenwind bekommen von der Datenschutzbehörde, dem Datenschutzrat,
was ein parteiübergreifendes Gremium ist, des Parlaments, dem Justizministerium,
den Autofahrerclubs, die sind sehr mächtig.
Amnesty International hat sich mit uns dagegen gestellt und ja,
wir haben genügend Gegenwind bekommen, dass ein paar Sachen schon nachgebessert wurden.
Wir waren letztens im Ministerium diese Woche und ein Hauptkritikpunkt,
nämlich der Echtzeitzugriff der Polizei, der ist schon draußen.
Aber ja, jetzt wird weiter verhandelt. Vielleicht kriegen wir es auch noch komplett verhindert.
Wir verlinken ein paar Analysen zu den Gesetzesentwürfen und auch zu der schönen
Demo, die wir gemacht haben in Wien vor der SPÖ-Zentrale, weil die SPÖ ist diejenige
Partei, die das Ganze vorantreibt.
Und vor ihrer Parteizentrale ist so einer der Orte, wo künftig wieder überwacht wird.
Und deswegen gibt es da jetzt auch schöne Bilder. Ja, und das ist so eines der
Österreich-Themen und ich finde es eigentlich wichtig, dass wir öffentlichen
Raum überwachungsfrei halten. Wir sind schon digital.
So stark überwacht, es ist so schwierig heutzutage noch unbeobachtet,
sich auszutauschen, zu organisieren, sich zu informieren oder erst recht politische
Meinungsäußerungen zu betreiben.
Wenn man jetzt auch noch in den Innenstädten, dort wo demonstriert wird,
die Kameras aufstellt, da wo Menschen Leben arbeiten und einkaufen gehen,
da hört es sich dann endgültig auf.
Und deswegen ist das so eine rote Linie, die wir gerade verteidigen.
Und im 19.
März ist der nächste Verkehrsausschuss. Bis dahin werden wir wissen,
ob diese Novelle ohne diesen Giftzahn der Innenstadtüberwachung über die Bühne
geht oder ob wir das noch verhindert oder bekommen oder es eine Reform gibt.
Und im Moment sind die Liberalen in Österreich, die Neos, noch unsere Hoffnung.
Waren ja bisher nur in der Opposition, seit es sie gibt. Das ist ihre erste
Regierungsbeteiligung. Die haben sich immer Bürgerrechte auf die Fahnen geheftet.
Wenn man mit den Abgeordneten redet, die sind alle ganz klar,
na das geht nicht, das ist unverhältnismäßig, das wollen wir nicht.
Vor allem Österreich hat ja auch ein riesiges Budgetproblem.
Wir müssen überall sparen.
Und dann will man den Gemeinden erlauben, so um zweistellige Millionenbeträge Kameras zu kaufen.
So viel kosten solche Systeme. Da haben wir auch schon mal Dokumente gelegt.
Ja, und dann entscheidet das Höchstgericht in einem Jahr, dass das alles illegal
war. Was macht man dann mit den Kameras aus der Kunst?
Also ja, die Liberalen, die Neos sind noch nicht das geworden,
was in Deutschland die FDP ist.
Es gibt manche Leute, die sie gerne dort sehen würden, die finden,
das ist eine coole Zukunft, so hardcore neoliberal zu sein.
Aber da gibt es auch noch Kräfte in der Partei, die sich dagegen wehren und
das ist auch so ein bisschen der Kampf, um den es hier geht.
Um die Seele der Liberalen.
Können die sich bei den Grundrechten sozusagen noch auf ihren Kern berufen oder
ist ihnen alles Wurscht für den Machterhalt?
Also in Deutschland hat das ja nicht funktioniert Ja Und da haben wir ja auch
gesehen, wohin das führt.
Ich glaube auch, dass es ein Irrweg ist Also gerade so eine 10%-Partei,
die aus dem liberalen Spektrum kommt Wenn die ihre Glaubwürdigkeit verliert,
können sie einpacken Die braucht dann keiner mehr Ja,
und ich hoffe, dass sie sich da auch ein Beispiel nehmen an Deutschland.
Und ich habe noch ein anderes Österreich-Thema.
Ein gutes Beispiel an Deutschland nehmen. Das hört man doch mal gerne.
Ja, sonst ist es immer die andere Richtung.
Ja, dann mein letztes Thema ist noch, das wäre auch ein guter Witz.
Tim sagt ein Anwalt zum anderen, na wie geht es dir? Und er sagt so,
na ich kann nicht klagen.
Wir haben zweimal geklagt, wir haben zweimal Verfassungsklage eingebracht in
Österreich gegen den Staat.
Und zwar einmal wegen dem Bundestrojaner, Staatstrojaner, also dieser Überwachungssoftware,
die in Österreich ja beschlossen wurde letztes Jahr.
Da sind wir zum Höchstgericht gegangen, gemeinsam mit der Opposition,
also mit den linken Grünen und mit den rechtsextremen FPÖ.
Gemeinsam sind wir, ja.
Das haben wir aber in der Vergangenheit auch schon gemacht. Also ich sage immer,
wenn ich die Gesetze abschaffen kann, die Überwachungsbefugnisse sind,
die dann den Innenminister Kickl auch zur Verfügung stünden, dann mache ich das.
Und an der Stelle ist es so, dass die beiden Oppositionsparteien dagegen waren
und jetzt uns auch ermöglichen, gegen das Gesetz zu klagen, noch bevor es in
Kraft ist. und das haben wir jetzt gemacht, die Klage ist eingebracht.
Sie ist auch sehr gut geworden, annähernd 100 Seiten stark und wirklich ganz
viele internationale Beispiele.
Wir haben ja 2019 schon mal mit den NEOS und der SPÖ, den Bundestrojaner,
weggeklagt und jetzt wollen wir das nochmal machen bei diesem neuen Gesetz,
dass es den Inlandsgeheimdienst erlauben würde,
einen Bundestrojaner einzusetzen und ja, wir hoffen, dass wir in den nächsten
drei bis neun Monaten eine Entscheidung vom Höchstgericht bekommen.
Und dass sie natürlich in unsere Richtung ausgeht. Das wäre das Ende des Bundestrojaners,
wenn wir es schaffen würden, dass wir das recyceln, weil dann waren jetzt fünf
Anläufe, die gescheitert sind.
Das Thema verfolgt Österreich ja jetzt schon seit zehn Jahren.
2016 war der erste Vorschlag dazu. Alle vorherigen vier konnten wir verhindern.
Und jetzt ist der fünfte eben unser jetziger großer Meilenstein.
Ja, das ist die eine Klage. Und die andere Klage?
Wann erwartet ihr da eine Entscheidung?
Naja, also das Gericht ist frei darin zu entscheiden, was es aufgreift,
welche Fälle und wie es die entscheidet.
Aber bei so einer abstrakten Normenkontrolle, wie das heißt,
das ist ein Antrag, der von einem Drittel der Abgeordneten im Parlament unterstützt wird,
ist es eigentlich so, dass die auch auf die Politik schauen und die wissen ja,
dieses Gesetz wird 2027 in Kraft treten.
Und jeder will vorher schon wissen, ist es jetzt legal oder nicht.
Deswegen recht nicht.
Also binnen diesen Jahres.
Ja, gehe ich davon aus.
Gut.
Und die andere Sache ist, Livestreams wollen wir einklagen von Untersuchungsausschüssen.
Das glaubt man gar nicht, aber in Österreich, wenn da ein Untersuchungsausschuss
tagt, dann tut er das medienöffentlich, aber nicht öffentlich.
Das heißt, man kann da nicht hin als interessierte Person, Und dem Ganzen beiwohnen.
Es gibt auch keinen Livestream, auch nicht von den Befragungen von einem Minister
oder einer Ministerin oder Sektionschefs, also Leuten, die eh schon Personen
des öffentlichen Interesses sind,
wo es keine schutzwürdigen Interessen gibt, weil das jetzt einfach nur private
Auskunftspersonen ist. Da könnte man ja einen Livestream machen.
Innerhalb des Parlaments gibt es den schon. Also wenn du als Medienvertreter
da rein willst und der Saal ist voll, dann gibt es so einen Overflow-Room,
wo du dann halt den Livestream schauen kannst.
Aber der wird nicht rausgegeben an die Öffentlichkeit, weil das die Verfahrensordnung,
die Geschäftsordnung des Nationalrats gerade nicht erlauben.
Und da klagen wir auch, wir haben auch, da bin ich ganz stolz drauf,
Entscheidungen aus den 90er Jahren gefunden, aus dem Tiroler Landtag,
wo unser Höchstgericht schon entschieden hat, na na, das...
Sollte wirklich öffentlich-öffentlich sein, wenn das Parlament seine Arbeit
tut und nicht nur für MedienvertreterInnen öffentlich sein.
Da hoffen wir, dass das uns auch hier gelingt, dass wir es endlich schaffen,
dass man in Zeiten der Informationsfreiheit dann auch von zu Hause aus der Aufklärungsarbeit
des Untersuchungsausschusses beifohnen kann.
Der Anlassfall ist, also hier können wir natürlich nicht ein Drittel der Abgeordneten
hinter uns subsumieren,
sondern wir haben das einfach mit vier normalen Menschen gemacht,
die beim Untersuchungsausschuss hingegangen sind und gesagt haben,
hey, ich würde da gerne rein, ich habe auch hier eine Kamera mit,
ich mache einen Livestream.
Die haben uns natürlich abgewiesen, weil die dürfen uns nicht reinlassen.
Und es gibt auch ein lustiges Video, wo man das genau hört, so na,
das ist nicht öffentlich, nur medienöffentlich.
Und damit haben wir die unmittelbare Betroffenheit, um zum Höchstgericht zu
gehen, weil ein anderes Rechtsmittel gibt es nicht.
Wir haben das letztes Jahr schon mal probiert, aber am letzten Tag des Untersuchungsausschusses
und als das Gericht dann entscheiden wollte, hat es gesagt, ja,
aber jetzt tagt kein Ausschuss mehr und deswegen können wir in der Sache nicht
entscheiden, weil ihr seid ja jetzt nicht mehr unmittelbar betroffen.
Und dieses Mal sind wir zum allerersten möglichen Termin, der erste medienöffentliche
Termin, eben hingegangen, um uns abweisen zu lassen. Und gleich am selben Tag
haben wir die Klage eingebracht.
Also hoffen wir, dass wir, das sollte auch dieses Jahr noch entschieden werden,
dann bald Livestreams von Untersuchungsausschüssen haben, powered by ABCenterWorks.
Schön. Ja, super Aktion. Ich finde das total richtig,
dass man da die Transparenz hat, weil gerade Untersuchungsausschüsse gehen ja
in der Regel dann auch wirklich auf die kniffligen politischen Fälle,
wo es eben auch sehr viel,
wo sagen wir mal eine politische Bewertung durch die Teilnehmer des Untersuchungsausschusses
ja nicht entkoppelt sein kann von einer Gesellschaftsmeinung.
Die auch in jedem Fall in der Lage sein muss, sich hier auch zu bilden.
Und was gibt es da Schöneres, als sich wirklich die vollständigen Untersuchungsvorgänge
und Aussagen der Befragung und so weiter direkt mitverfolgen zu können,
beziehungsweise auch in dokumentierter Form nachhören und schauen zu können.
Und es gibt da auch wieder sehr schöne österreichische Gründe, wieso wir das brauchen.
Also es gab legendäre Befragungen von unserem damaligen Finanzminister,
und er hat, glaube ich, fast 50 Mal gesagt, dass er sich an irgendwas nicht erinnert.
Unter anderem so, besitzen sie also einen Laptop.
Wusste er nicht mehr. Später hat sich
herausgestellt, weil es ging um eine Hausdurchsuchung bei ihm zu Hause.
Und seine Frau hat den Laptop in den Kinderwagen gegeben und ist mit dem Kinderwagen
dann spazieren gegangen, sodass die Polizei den nicht findet.
Er wusste natürlich schon im Vorfeld, dass gleich eine Hausdurchsuchung bei ihm sein wird.
Und wir haben ganz oft so komische Erinnerungslücken, wo die Leute dann halt
unter Wahrheitspflicht nicht lügen wollen und deswegen,
sich leider nicht erinnern können und das ist natürlich erst durch eine kritische
Öffentlichkeit, die diesem Trauerspiel beiwohnt, möglich abzustellen,
weil das überlebst du politisch halt nicht, wenn du nicht einmal mehr weißt, wie du heißt.
Es ist mir nicht erinnerlich,
Das ist so die klassische Aussage. Naja.
Du weißt ja, in Österreich ist der Konjunktiv in der Höflichkeitsform.
Hast du mal ein Beispiel für?
Da könnte ich vielleicht noch einen Kaffee haben.
Also wäre es möglich oder könnte es, kann man aber auch so ein bisschen ins Englische übersetzen.
Ich finde das nicht immer schlecht. Also das mit dem Höfischen und Höflichen,
das kann man schon ganz gut.
Gut, das war unser Blick in die EU, ein bisschen nach Deutschland,
ein bisschen nach Österreich.
Das nächste Mal musst du dann was von Südafrika erzählen, ich bin ganz gespannt.
Ja, da kann ich jetzt noch nicht so viel berichten, außer dass es hier warm ist im Sommer.
Ich beneide dich, hier nicht.
Kann ich feststellen, ja. Aber ich war hier auch noch nicht jetzt groß auf Reisen.
Aber ich nehme das zur Kenntnis, wie man das immer so zur Kenntnis nimmt,
wenn man so in so einem anderen Gesellschaftssystem ist, dann sind ja immer
die Unterschiede immer ganz interessant.
Und ja, da gibt es auf jeden Fall einige.
Das kann ich schon mal in Aussicht stellen.
Oh ja, auch die ganze Apartheid-Geschichte hat so viele interessante Dinge zu
beobachten, dieses District Museum.
Ich war zweimal dort und ich habe es wirklich sehr genossen.
Du wirst viel Spaß haben und schau zu den Pinguinen und sag Hallo für uns.
Ja, genau. Geht nicht.
Okay, wir sagen Tschüss und bis bald.
Ciao.